I want a meeting with all the remaining heads.
We need to stabilize the situation
before it spirals out of control.
Wouldn't that candidate have emerged by now?
That's the question that remains for so many people.
Is that candidate even out there?
Describe their ideal candidate
It turns out most voters want somebody
who is a fighter, bare knuckle brawler would do
well in this race.
An outsider, somebody who is not afraid
to take on the establishment.
which works against the career politicians
There are legitimate problems in the city right now,
and the voters want somebody who understands the pain
they're going through,
There's no doubt it is late in the process,
but there's still a window of opportunity.
That's what the poll is telling us.
It could be anybody.
Welcome back everyone, It's Charlie
They just released the Echo Series
This will be my video for the Post-Credits Scene.
The Ending was
basically a big daredevil born again teaser
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
they just started reshooting Daredevil Born Again,
like Vincent D'Onofrio was talking about them
getting ready to work on episodes.
So we'll get more footage from the actual series
pretty soon.
Echo is basically meant to set that up.
careful for spoilers from the ending of Echo
if you haven't seen it yet, I do have a longer video
plan for Easter eggs from the entire series,
This video will just be
for the ending the post-credits scene
like how it sets up Daredevil born again.
so in the final episode, Echo has essentially unlocked
her cosmic powers
that she gets biologically from her ancestors.
the original Choctaw Native Americans
I know they're going to be a ton of questions
about how her powers work. Like, who are these people?
What is going on inside this cave?
this is meant to be the MCU adaptation of the real life
Choctaw Nation's origin story myth.
so in real life
the Choctaw have their own creation myth.
and this is them basically saying that in the MCU,
the Choctaw actually came
from this alternate dimension based on the Choctaws
real life beliefs,
they just tuned it up a little bit,
made a little bit more cosmic for the MCU version.
like during the series
you keep seeing her ancestor Choppa here,
who was a different type of being
that was transformed into a human when she was knocked
into the main dimension like she existed in this other
little pocket dimension here before it was destroyed.
No, there'd be a lot of questions about that, too.
Right now, it seems like that has something to do
with the Kang Multiverse War.
so there's a little bit of crossover
because we're all heading up to Avengers Secret Wars,
and so everything is meant to connect
finally by secret wars,
which is why I think that is what is happening here,
to destroy this pocket dimension,
throwing all of her ancestors into the main dimension,
the way they depict her powers.
They seem like Captain America level
just a little tuned up.
Like she has the ability
to throw people into their memories, to heal people.
But it's not something on the level of, say,
like Thor's powers.
but the whole idea of the ending here
is that she basically rejects
kingpin in his violence, tries to genuinely help him.
To her credit, even though it seems like
he's just completely shaken by he winds up taking off
at the end of the series just because he's so messed up
by having to revisit his childhood trauma.
but if it wasn't clear he leaves of his own volition.
Like he's not trying to kill Echo
or force her to come back any more.
so basically she is free for the most part.
probably still wanted by the law for a bunch of murders
that she committed
for Kingpin Back in the day, though,
she killed a lot of people for Kingpin.
they basically end the series, though,
with a fast and furious style
family dinner,
like all about family, post all the memes.
when we get to the actual post-credits scene, though,
this is meant to be the big daredevil born again teaser
you see Kingpin on his jet ready to fly back home
to New York City, ordering a meeting with the remaining
heads of all the crime families in New York
who essentially work as his underboss.
Like Kingpin is meant to be
the boss of bosses in New York.
I know.
There are a lot of questions about how powerful he was
during the events of Hawkeye because of the five year
time jump like what happened during that.
There are a couple flashbacks during the series
to the events of the five year time jump.
they revealed the kingpin did not get snapped.
So he was around during that entire period.
And it sounds like
he gained a lot of the city's territory
during that period,
like he took over a lot of the crime families.
on the jet.
The situation that he referenced.
Is this in danger of spiraling out of control?
Is the fallout that's been happening to his
organization since the events of the Hawkeye Series?
he sees the broadcast about the upcoming race
for mayor of New York City
and is inspired to run when the broadcasters say
that there's no strong candidate, the city is in dire
need of someone who understands the plight
of the people in the best way to fix the city.
somebody who's a bare knuckle brawler
who isn't afraid to fight with the other career
politicians in in the comics, Kingpin
actually is a champion fighter.
He just way way bigger in the comics
who is way more physically powerful.
when he leans in and they play that ominous music,
the whole idea is that he believes
he knows the right way to fix New York City.
Like his way is the best way,
as you would expect Kingpin to believe
But essentially that amounts to him running New York
like his own personal playground fantasy,
doing whatever he deems to be right in
trying to get rid of anybody that he doesn't like.
namely the heroes, vigilantes like Daredevil,
Spider-Man, Punisher.
So part of the idea is that when Daredevil Born Again
picks up, he'll be running from it.
Like he'll be in the middle of running for mayor
during those early episodes.
I think I talked about this all the way back
when the Hawkeye episodes were happening.
A couple of years ago,
because they'd had this plot in place for a while.
Like they wanted to foreshadow Kingpin
eventually becoming mayor of New York City
like he did in the comics during the Devils Reign era.
part of the idea
is that he runs for mayor on an anti vigilante campaign
and uses that as an excuse to go after people
like Daredevil, Spider-Man, Punisher.
Those are their vigilante level
characters, street level characters
it's part of this whole Marvel Phase five Dark Reign
era going on in the MCU.
Thunderbolt
Ross is doing that with the office of a U.S.
president like he doesn't on a national level,
The whole idea is that on a street
level, things are kind of thrown into chaos.
Like things just start going crazy
and you have a bunch of people like Thunderbolt
Ross and Kingpin coming in saying that, No, no,
I know how to fix things.
But essentially they're ruling their territories,
either New York City or the United States
with an iron fist
turning things into something akin to a police state.
if you didn't read the Dark Reign era in the comics,
essentially it's Norman Osborn who sort of
takes over this kind of role like he takes over shield,
he takes over the Avengers in replaces
the traditional Avengers
with a bunch of career criminals who are like
more hardcore stabby versions of the characters
inside the MCU, they're kind of replacing that role
with the Thunderbolts team.
Vincent D'Onofrio was actually asked about this, too.
Like, what does Kingpin actually want to do
in the way he talks about it?
He basically just says Kingpin is going to get
whatever he wants, which he always does.
know, Kingpin is back for sure,
and he's going to get what he wants, like romance.
That's what's going to happen.
So this whole idea with Mayor Kingpin,
like whether it's right or wrong in reality,
if he thinks it's right,
if he's something that he wants, he's going to do
whatever it takes to actually get it.
getting to the whole Spider-Man of it all, too,
because there's been all this talk about Spider-Man
four and Kingpin
going up against Spider-Man or Spider-Man teaming up
with Daredevil against Kingpin at some point.
So. Because Spider-Man movies
tend to always have animal
themed villains like really big splashy
comic book level villains
So even though Kingpin is a longtime
Spider-Man villain in the comics like Spider-Man,
that animated series back in the nineties
did a lot of Spider-Man versus Kingpin.
They even had a Daredevil Team-Up episode
where they teamed up against Kingpin yet to age
on a live action version of that happening,
even though that was a big thing for a long time
in the comics, I don't think that Kingpin
would be the main villain of something
like Spider-Man four or even Spider-Man five.
Kevin Foggy did say that what happens during Daredevil
born again, like this whole Major Kingpin story arc,
will heavily influence
what's happening during the events of Spider-Man four.
so if you played Spider-Man PS4, you have to imagine
that Kingpin felt like Spider-Man versus Kingpin.
We might actually get a version
of that during Spider-Man four.
really Early theory
The Kingpin might have something to do with hiring
other Spider-Man villains
to actually go after Spider-Man just by himself.
Though MCU Kingpin isn't quite physically powerful
enough to actually take on Spider-Man
in the comics, it's a little bit different.
Like he's way, way bigger, way stronger in the comics.
in if it wasn't clear
when this echo Post-Credits scene is happening,
it's still the year 2025 in the MCU.
And in present day of the MCU,
we passed Guardians of the Galaxy three Dazzle in 2026.
So technically this series is a bit of a flashback.
I believe the events of Daredevil Born Again
are meant to pick up during 2026, though,
so like a little bit of time
will have gone by after this post-credits scene.
vote for Kingpin Mayor Fisk.
yet imagine his slogans all over the place.
There was a little bit of Daredevil
born again footage that actually released last year
when they were still filming
before the big strike happened
and there were a bunch of banners
about voting for Fisk.
Just imagine the tracksuit bros
just placing fliers all over the place.
Vote for a bro. Come on, bro. Trust you, bro.
we didn't really see any Punisher stuff
going on during Echo,
even though they used a lot of Punisher language,
like no bad deed goes
unpunished, why would you use that language
if you weren't going to reference the Punisher at all?
But the Punisher is meant to come back
during Daredevil Born Again.
He'll be a main character during the series.
I believe he's meant to be going after corrupt cops
when the series picks up.
But you all remember Daredevil season two
or the Punisher during that you have to imagine
that same kind of vibe again,
except that they're working together a little bit more.
But Punisher is also kind of doing his own thing
on the side.
the other really good news
you probably just saw in your feeds is that Marvel
just canonize all the Marvel Netflix series, too.
The MCU stuff that's happening right now.
So if there was any question all that Marvel
Netflix defenders stuff is canon to the MCU,
they literally just put all those shows in the MCU
timeline on the Disney Plus page here, too.
They released a big trailer, too,
with a bunch of footage just to hammer home
that all this daredevil stuff
that happened during the original series is can't add
to what happens in present day.
Now, they just restarted production on Daredevil
born again.
They got one of the showrunners from The Punisher
in a bunch of the Loki writers
to actually do the series now, which actually
makes me way more excited about the series.
Like I was pumped up about a new Daredevil series.
But when you hear The Punisher writers in the Loki
writers are working on it
it just seems that they're going all out
to make it amazing the way things are going.
Right now, though,
it seems like they'll be able to premiere Daredevil
Born Again before Spider-Man four, which is why
I think the kingpin will be mayor of New York City
when Spider-Man four eventually picks up.
and because Daredevil Kingpin
are now officially back on it.
The be lots of questions about the other Marvel
defenders characters like Luke Cage,
Jessica Jones, Iron Fist.
We know that Luke Cage is not going to be recast,
but my culture is super busy right now, booked on
other TV series, so they're just waiting for him
to become available again.
Jessica Jones was supposed to come back earlier
in Daredevil Born Again, but I think they delayed
that lady.
She's a story just a little bit,
but she will be coming back eventually
and I just did a video about them
actually bringing back the iron fist character
but they're actually supposed to bring back the ancient
iron fist, the very first iron fist in the timeline,
not the thin Jones version of iron fist
from present day, the Danny Rand version.
another going to be a ton of questions about
some of the things that they set up in this series.
So I'll post my longer breakdown video
of all the Easter eggs in the next day or so.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
And if you do have any specific questions,
just post them in the comments below
and I'll add them to that video everyone click here
for that brand new Deadpool 3 teaser
trailer video and click here to learn about Iron Fist
coming back in the MCU.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!